les jours sont 230 les non sont 197 le président
renouvelle sohcahtoa Ready Set compter même l'
abstention une Pâque historique Donald
Trump actuel deuxième président un citoyen
II faire via le butin était iam chef que l'Amérique
MS l'inoculation ne se soucie pas de
vous la misère pauvre abattoir Yakov
aurait un au Congrès, il ne nous a pas donné le
choix
FX est une action irresponsable s'il vous plaît Donna
nouvelle Zappa Donnell schwa je me sens s'il vous plaît
ne faites pas Lashon Nancy Pelosi donc Noel
Donald Trump représente à Manas la sécurité
nationale le président est à nouveau une
menace permanente pour notre national  sécurité
le président et ses hommes complotent sur un
chef démocrate Adam Kadhafi il laissera la
démocratie apparaître il notre démocratie est un
péril de voir de nouveaux pouvoirs sur un cas Jones similaire
un mangeur de viande démocrate Sasori nous avons
besoin de la capitale du coffre pourquoiyyy un massage a
été délivré à  faites-le sortir, nous devons l'
enlever, c'est un criminel
Donald trum à une fête où vous êtes assis sur
des fournitures criminelles, notre prison de
Valera crouppen
cela signifie au moins mettre des parents  d d'une
limite sur ses limiteurs d'information de puissance
ou pouvoir je suis terry steel sydney mais de
cette façon si une bizarrerie est préférée au
verbe de compétence qu'il veut faire
le président n'a rien fait de mal dans ce
problème mais a commencé un voyage Lisa V
républicain a profité verrouillé  en parallèle un
traumatisme pauvres ils connaissent voyez les possesseurs
vous savez ils disent regardez et ça a été une
mise en accusation à la recherche d'un crime citroen
destitution notre chef faisant clémence
Steve Scalise prendre cette histoire
Loudermilk Lee Napa zzt accompagner Donald
Trump avoir une liste de clics quand Jésus était
faussement accusé de trahison, ne supposez pas
qu'un être ne mange pas jusqu'à ce que le poste de pelote
poursuivi par Dhoni soit physiquement
bouclé démocrate aucun nautique ne continue sur a
accordé plus de droits à Jésus que les
démocrates n'ont accordé à ce président
lorsque l'oppression habitant total maintenant Donald
Trump nous utilisons un  victime de la vapeur le PDB
Vanessa donc Sierra
n'a pas vraiment l'impression que nous sommes
destitués divorcé disap un revenu
Michigan non s'il vous plaît ne dites pas bien réglé
pour  La voiture Vidal d'un oncle de pois passe le
sélecteur dans un sac à main ouvert, nous voyons que c'est une
pilule qui est si la décence du coup d'État
pour insulter la propagande de Nick masazi c'est depuis le premier
jour que ce ne sont que des mensonges et le
propriétaire qu'il y a aussi de l'
hostilité Volpone sur les emplois répertoriés pour  le
von Osten maintenant un républicain alors imaginez
dire où en VF danke républicain
démocrate Moscou à VFX est la plupart des gens un
doozy m8 Abdul a dit procédure la
destitution si elle est plus malodorante quand elle est
terminée ma jamais voir Pascal
possible Sudha hooli asana une
réplique dominante de l'USNavy certains  un solitaire dans un
service de rayon alimentaire détourner l'air du poker
La parole de Donald Trump au milieu de voir le producteur SATA fonctionnel
Hades illa précède le
lancement de la soumission de Pomona Erica a
déclaré que Masonic utilise une variété solaire voir
Claire dans - Susan CV reprendre l'
avocat de la demande télévisée Cal F perte savoir
sûrement  abrogation essentielle du silicium sur le
pasa vampeur donc miséricorde pour l'énergie fossile